my half-sister who I hadn't seen for
over a decade and that was only for a
day and a half suddenly it felt like she
was everywhere I don't know your middle
name I don't know your birthday you're
telling these people that you raised me
and you've coined me Princess pushy
Meghan markle's half-sister Samantha
Markle has filed a defamation lawsuit
against her according to Court docs
obtained by E.T which were filed on
Friday Samantha is suing Megan for
defamation based on demonstrably false
and malicious statements made to a
worldwide audience
ET has reached out to Megan and Harry
for comment
Samantha specifically calls out Megan
and her hubby Prince Harry's 2021
interview with Oprah Winfrey and alleges
that Megan published and disseminated
false and malicious statements about her
in the 2020 biography finding Freedom
Harry and Megan and the making of a
modern royal family the lawsuit alleges
that Megan's comments about Samantha
were lies designed to destroy Samantha's
reputation and have subjected Samantha
to humiliation shame and hatred on a
worldwide scale
I hadn't had her fall out with her we
didn't have a closeness to be able to
have that
and I wanted a sister Samantha also
claims that Megan projected a false rags
to royalty narrative which came at the
expense of demeaning Samantha and their
father's reputations
we lived in a normal little house in
Woodland Hills California little
cul-de-sac Street nice neighbors so when
the media suggested that she was the
Cinderella that just rose up out of
rubbish or out of nowhere no that is
rubbish Samantha also denies claims that
she and Meg didn't spend much time
together growing up and denies being a
high school dropout what was your role
in her life do you remember when she was
born oh yeah yeah
um it was really kind of exciting
because I was going to have a little
sister but at that time I didn't realize
gee there's such a huge age disparity
um but for me it was like you know I I
definitely got to play big sister help
teach her to walk have fun with that she
also denies a claim She Says Megan made
that Samantha changed her last name to
Markle after news first broke that Megan
and Harry were dating Samantha is
seeking damages to the tune of seventy
five thousand dollars and is requesting
a trial by jury of course the Bad Blood
between Samantha and Megan has been
playing out in the public eye for over
five years but in 2018 Samantha insisted
she was not cashing in on her
half-sister's Fame despite frequently
criticizing Megan in the media let's
face it you know we all have to survive
money makes the world go round so if you
want to call that cashing in that's fine
but I think
um you know no one in media would refuse
a paycheck for talking about the Royals
and as a family we're not subject to
Royal protocol
[Music]
thank you